[Musik]
berlin neukölln das corona virus bricht
mitten in der hauptstadt aus 64 meter
sind in diesem haus infiziert und keiner
der bewohner darf mehr auf die straße
sowie rosa ag und ihr mann
es ist tag elf der quarantäne und sie
müssen in ihrer einzimmerwohnung
ausharren übers handy schildert sie ihre
lage ist für mich immer auf das
messegeschäft schrank oder arbeit den
block dürfen sie nicht verlassen nur den
innenhof betreten einkaufen gehen
unmöglich die lebensmittelvorräte waren
nach ein paar tagen aufgebraucht
hier geht lieber durch ein haus irgendwo
fragt wie geht's denn ein wenn sie
versorgt oder er
ich meine das ja auch kinder natürlich
kommt ja nicht alle tage vor dass ein
ganzer block früh gemacht wird und wir
können uns hier untereinander konnten
wir uns hier ist großartig helfen
kein zimmer und überversorgung gehen
oder privat mit
also ging er hat alles nicht nur durch
die medien der polizei vor ort ein
kreatives stimmung ja selbst der
hauseigentümer wurde davon überrascht
auch wir haben es aus der zeitung
erfahren wir haben auch mit dem
gesundheitsamt kontakt aufgenommen wir
haben sofort das gesundheitsamt
angesprochen wir haben sofort dem bezirk
angesprochen man hat uns jegliche
informationen verweigert man hat es
nicht gegeben
krisensitzung mit dem zuständigen
gesundheitsrat falko liecke wie sich das
virus so schnell verbreiten konnte und
wo sich die bewohner angesteckt haben
können nicht mehr nachvollzogen werden
hat seine behörde zu spät reagiert wir
sind ja nicht geübt in solchen verfahren
sondern das ist das erste mal dass
überhaupt in berlin ein ganzes haus oder
mehrere haus aufgänge unter quarantäne
gestellt wurde das war jetzt auch kein
böser akt sondern eine notwendige
maßnahme und von daher könnte auch
fehler passieren das will ich auch
einräumen
in dem neuköllner haus wohnen viele
menschen auf engstem raum str historiker
lebt in einer dreizimmerwohnung und hat
acht kinder die normalerweise in die
kita und in die schule gehen
es ist eine schwere situation es ist
warm hier sind viele kinder
aber wir müssen weitermachen so sind die
regeln
annaberger dolmetsch bei konflikten im
haus sie kennt die bewohner gut und weiß
wie finanziell eng es bei vielen
familien ist selbst für einfache hygiene
mittel ist oft kein geld da in
krisensituationen sie manche produkte so
teuer dass man als normaler mensch oder
schwach sozialen nicht sich nicht
leisten kann desinfektionsmittel ja die
kaufen desinfektionsmittel der kostet 15
euro eine flasche denken sie bei acht
kinder die alle die hände desinfizieren
lassen wie viel das kostet
die sozialen folgen der korona pandemie
untersucht yamaha sich vom berliner
wissenschaftszentrum wer arm ist sei
stärker gefährdet sich mit dem virus zu
infizieren
das fängt beim infektionsrisiko an das
ganz stark von den arbeitsbedingungen
abhängt kann jemals ist home office
wechseln oder muss er jeden tag in den
betrieb gehen es geht weiter bei den
wohnverhältnissen inwiefern kann ich
mich auch von meinen familienmitgliedern
ist die wohnung groß genug um mich von
meinen familienmitgliedern zu
distanzieren abstand zu den zu halten
wenn die erkältung symptome zeigen und
da ist natürlich ganz klar wenn ich mit
zehn menschen in der drei zimmer wohnung
lebe dass das schwierig wird nach einer
neuen studie der aok haben hartz 4
bezieher ein um 84 prozent höheres
risiko wegen einer corona infektion ins
krankenhaus zu kommen dann ist es so
dass diese bevölkerungsgruppen eine
erhöhte rate von vorerkrankungen
mitbringt beispielsweise erhöhte
fettleibigkeit erhöht
erkrankungen der atemwege die das risiko
schwerer verläufe und letztlich auch die
sterblichkeit erhöhen
das corona virus trifft ärmere menschen
besonders hart denn sie haben nicht das
geld um lebensmittel vorräte anzulegen
beim technischen hilfswerk in neukölln
werden auf die schnelle lebensmittel für
die unter quarantäne stehenden häuser
organisiert auch der
bezirksbürgermeister ist vor ort
wenn jetzt die reichen getroffen hätte
würden welche nicht leben und würden
irgendwie care pakete packen das heißt
irgendwie wir haben zu beginn und wie
das virus als phänomen nennt skiclubs
gehabt sie hatten das irgendwie bei den
roten in clubs feiern gegangen sind und
jetzt halt bei denen angekommen
die nicht feiern gehen die keine kohle
mit dem großen bruder die zu hause
gehortet haben und diejenigen brauchen
halt doch wesentlich mehr unterstützung
das thw rückt an lebensmittel als erste
hilfe auch für rosa ag und die anderen
bewohner bis ende der woche bleibt ihr
haus noch unter quarantäne
[Musik]